تناولنا كثير من الموضوعات
المشتركه التي تهم السودان وتهم الاقليم
جزائر بحكم موقفها
ومواقفها الثابته وعضويتها التي نالتها عن
جدار الان احنا بنحييه وبنه نهم على
عضويتهم في مجلس الامن نتوقع ان تستمر هذه
الدوله القويه في دعم ومناصر الحق الوطني
وحقوق الشعوب في انها تحيا حياه كريمه
تحدثنا في كثير من اوجه التعاون وجدنا
تفهم تام وترحاب بكل قضايا التعاون
المتوقعه والمرجو في
انها تنفذ وتستمر بين
دولتنا السودان معلوم يتعرض الان الى
مؤامره نحن نقول مؤامره شركاء اقليميين
ودوليين
بعض المشتراه النفوس المشتراه من الوطنيين
يتامر على شعبهم لكن هذا الامر في النهايه
الاراده الشعبيه الصادقه الوطنيه ستنتصر
وفي النهايه السودان سيقف من جديد بفضل
الله سبحانه وتعالى وبفضل شعبه وبفضل
مسانده الوطنيين من ابناء هذه الامه
العربيه والاسلاميه تحيه للقياده
الجزائريه مره اخرى تحيه للشعب الجزائري
ونكرر شكرنا وتقديرنا الكبير جدا
وامتناننا لما لمسناه من تفهم لقضايا
السودان ومن ترحاب بالمشاركه في تذليله
احنا سعيدين فيان الجزائر تكون حاضره في
طاوله اي طاوله للنقاش او للحوار اذا كانت
طاوله افريقيه او طاوله عربيه فهم نصر
للحق لذلك نحن نرحب بهم دوما ونريد ان نرى
حلول السلميه تسير ا بصوره جيده حتى
نستطيع ان نتجاوز هذه
المحنه